thank you Jason uh I'm like Ray uh the
word noil does not on my slide I start
with the word residue first it's residue
that protects the soil it's residue
that's helping feed the soil system it's
residue is what I want to keep out there
now Dwayne's talking after me so I'm not
sure what all he's going to cover but I
had the benefit of watching these three
guys in front of me to know what they're
talked about and I actually had two
different presentations loaded for
today and the one was a more in-depth on
cover crops how to and what all all it
can do for you the other was more for
them the residue and soil structure well
in the original program came
out Jim Herman was going to talk more
about cover crops what' he do he
switched more to soil biology and I'm
like or soil compaction so I'm like all
right which
presentation this is a
blend it's called adjust on the go the
beauty of PowerPoint and computer so
anyway when it comes down to it I make a
statement Point Blank Jim talked about
so compaction statement point blank is
tillage has never built soil structure
tillage destroys the existing soil
structure now if you got a bad structure
like compaction and you can reach it
with your tillage implant and you break
up the soil structure the bad compaction
that's good right but what if you have a
good structure or what if you have the
compassion and you break that up you
broke up all the structures there the
next pass in the field can create more
compaction it's a vicious circle when it
comes to tillage but when I look at
tillage and I started thinking about
Water Management years ago there's some
researchers saying studying the soil
said you know the average silt B soil
holds 2 inch of water per foot you tell
it 6 inches deep that's one inch water
affected about half of it goes away
that's how these kind of numbers show up
now half inch in an average year before
planting who cares maybe I have
irrigation maybe I got another spring
rain coming maybe the soil's too wet
anyway and you got to till it to dry it
out you've all heard that never do that
by the way but when you start thinking
about it what if we did in the olden
days there was three four tillage passes
half inch per trip we dried out 2 Ines
of water remember 2 inches per foot the
olden days everybody had fur openers and
their Planters trying to push away dry
so and clouds trying to find moisture to
plant
into that's expensive half inch per trip
now very few of us do four trips anymore
pre-plan you know some guys are down on
one trip some guys are one in the fall
one in the spring whatever but I start
looking at that where's my residue
where's my so biological life think
about what else is going on out there
without residue there to keep the wind
off Sol surf we have wind erosion
problems without residue there absorb
raindrop impact that energy detaches
those solil particles then they start
washing on us you we still got a triple
whammy here we got the yellow
unproductive soil up there because all
the good stuff washed away we got the
gullies there where washed out crop cut
some gullies h on the sprayer going
across them down at the bottom sealed in
some
crop that's all because of lack of
residue to absorb Rain Drive Impact and
a lack of soil structure to let the
water soak in where it lands and again
tillage erases all that so we want to go
away from the tillage now even if you
don't have slopes and erosion problems
there's still an infiltration problem
you know I growing up many many years
ago in northeast Nebraska I thought it
was great to have a crust in the
soil dad put me out on the tractor says
you get to drive 10 m hour the rotary
hole trying to break that
up wait a minute that's not great
when you look at that you know this
farmer is digging in screwdriving and if
you know where to look you can almost
see corn plants trying to come through
there I look at the other wave cop can't
get up more importantly the water can't
get in if water can't get in it's going
to run off so again I want to build
structure now I say this is many years
ago uh we got Farmers now that cut way
back on tillage they're leaving residue
out there we had to the 85 Farm Bill
said residue cover it's going to solve
our erosion problems it didn't quite it
helped but when it comes down to it
we're still doing ourselves a favor when
it comes to soil structure 1981 I
received a grant for three years to
study different tillage systems I
actually started working with noil in 78
with my Master's thesis in 81
established a set of plots Southeast
Nebraska about 10 miles east of Lincoln
to Sly clay LOM soil and Dryland and at
that time grain sorum soybeans were
popular crops for Dryland Nebraska Corn
varieties weren't quite there yet for
that location of the state so I did
grain start sing rotation for a number
of years this picture was taken about
the
mid90s I loved no till I loved the
residue now remember I started no
tilling back before we had cheap glyos
you know at that time Roundup was only
about $100 a gallon I learned a no tail
without that now be truthful today I do
love Roundup Ready beans as such I hate
Roundup Ready corn with my crop rotation
I don't want to use Round Up in the corn
year we don't and I don't because we put
down our early pre-plant get it rained
in and activated and that's what we
learned back in the 80s when we didn't
have all the post emerged products our
pre-emerge products rained in couple
weeks had of planting when I plant all
my moisture all my nutrients are there
for my crop weeds haven't been using
them the other thing is I love the
residue every Bean is up and growing
because the soil moisture was protected
it's not going to crust not going to
wash out not going to dry out in the
tilled side there's some beans under
crust or some beans in dry soil some
beans never going to grow but when it
really comes to soil health take a look
at the average elevation of this soil
surface compared to this over here
there's about a 4 in Step there that
many years of tillage compared to that
many years of not
tilling Jim talked about it sand silt
and Clays and organic materials those
are our solids in the soil the air space
the POR space is air and water should be
about half por space half solids as I
come through doing tillage I break up
the soil structure the solids are not
compressed what happens is the pores are
squeezed out of the soil particles
between them and what happens is they
reappear on top a lack of soil structure
this soil is denser than this this soil
has less pore space those less pores
fill up with water quicker soil gets
saturated quicker and worse than that it
dries out quicker because you don't have
the storage there and so a lot of guys
with Tilly say well my soils are too wet
well they're too wet for a couple days
and they're too dry in the next couple
of days no mine is a lot more buffered
and that's what I like about soil
structure and again lot of guys say well
no tail it has to be continuous no tail
to get the soil Health has to be a
continuously fed soil system to get the
soil Health you know the year he planted
this corn no tilling to the bean residue
yes he saved trips not doing till saved
some fuel save some labor but that's
still a till soil when it comes to
crusting when it comes to runoff when it
comes to lack of infiltration when it
comes to lack of so biological life so
it's continuous no till it does it and
here's an example of about 12 years
continuous no till here we can see some
good PS and Aggregates like Ray talked
about we can see where water can soak in
we can see where Roots can penetrate
walked across the fence this is the same
soil type continuous tillage you can
imagine Heavy Rain you can see why we
get runoff or flat soils you can see why
we get
ponding again I want to build that soil
structure to get that healthy soil out
there again the tillage destroys it
rapidly you know the disc is one of the
worst offenders that was to developed as
a compaction tool to build roads to BU
break up existing solil structure and
create a subgrade compaction layer to
build a road I don't know why we thought
we could use it in farming systems but
when you start thinking about it again I
showed this for compaction uh Jim talked
about compaction the full width tailing
compaction you hardly ever see I saw it
because I had no tail next to it Jim
said compare it to your fence row you
can see how that's been beat down yes it
looks like it's been fluffed up but that
weight of that disc has been carried
underneath and on wet soils the wet soil
particles are lubricated they compact
more easily again earlier I said you may
have heard it say I got to till that
what Sol dried out it's exactly the
worst time to till it when it comes to
soil health because it does destroy soil
structure now some people say I'm going
to till shallower I'm G get one of these
new colder tillage tools that's exactly
the worst layer to till that's the one
with your Sol biological life you're
trying to build why destroy that and
then pack below it where you're trying
to put the seed the other form of
compaction is shown back here wheel
traffic compaction typically Wheel
tracks are as deep as you till because
again till you erase soil structure
there's nothing there to support you so
again it's a vicious circle here now
wheel traffic compaction larger tires
reduced PSI more footprint on the ground
more axles to carry the load that's how
I reduce those and build soil structure
how reduce those but even if the soil's
dry you're not doing yourself a favor
doing
tillage yes I'm breaking up clouds why
we created them with previous tillage
pass now this is going to be an extreme
example this is a wheat F producer out
in western
Nebraska he is an organic weak fellow
producer so every time he's got a flush
of weeds he does another tillage trip
now earlier I said tillage doesn't build
soil structure I'm wrong tillage
actually built a soil structure that we
call massive it has taken every poor
space out of that soil now the soil
surface is Right Above This the residue
is just sort of hanging down into this
hole that we dug below this he's been
discing on his first pass and then he
switches over sweeps and blades and we
found layers in there you could actually
pick that up and you could find the
shmear mark from the blade the sweep or
whatever that ran in there now depending
upon the year he had anything between 13
to about 18 19 trips for tillage on his
wheat fellow rotation because remember
he has about 14 months he's doing
tillage look below that layer though
some beautiful soil structure that free
Tha weding and drying builds but you
know what if my roots can't get there my
water can't get there this down here
doesn't make any sense doesn't make any
difference don't do the tillage on top
organic wheat fow Ray Ward and I walked
out there and Ray we should have paid
attention I should have made a crisper
footprint but take a look at that
footprint take a look at that soil take
a look at the lack of biological
life does it look much different than
that Neil Armstrong we all know there's
no life in the moon I'm not sure there's
much more life in that soil is there
again we've done some dumb things at
tillage you know this is a native soil
structure out there the grass that was
built by having a Living Root in that
soil system that was actually growing
there 10 11 12 months a year depending
on where you're at what the winter is
like and it's having a Living Root
putting carbon down in there that's the
darker soil we see as we lose everything
on top and as we erode that away we get
down to this again to rebuild that we
need to get carbon back down in there
that's Roots that's going to be our
cover crops our cash crops it's going to
be perennial crops to rebuild it the
fastest because perennial crops would
sent the roots Down Deeper that's what
built this to start with was perennial
grasses or a mixture of trees grasses
Forbes whatever out there again let's go
back a little bit in history and some of
the dumb things we've done you know the
more word plow everyone says I got to
plow that soil to make a seed bed you
can still go to the farm progress show
and see plows being demonstrated yes
they're still being sold but we start
thinking about what we're doing we're
breaking up all the existing soil
structure we're coming in there taking
that non-uniform seed bed and we're
going in there and doing discing field
cultivation or whatever and this is a
real bad example here this is a at alurn
Alabama National soil tilth lab the
compaction layer of the plow pan where
the plow packed below that then you can
see some secondary pans from the discs
and field cators you see no soil
structure up here in the root Zone look
down below though beautiful soil
structure but again if the water and
Roots can't get to it we're in trouble
I'm an egg engineer by training egg
Engineers figured out a long time ago
you know you take a stick out here a
shank and put it down below this layer
and as you drag it through there it's
going to fracture at a 50 or about a 45°
angle so you put it 50% deep and put
another shank over here fracture that I
can fracture I can break up the bad soil
structure compaction right the chisel
plow was
born 12 in shank space and 12 in deep
you go through there and you break up
the bad so structure of the compaction
of the plow layer and you come back and
you smooth it out pack it back down
after a few years you took
a all right which one of you two were
the plower and chisler these two are
laughing he took a plow pan from 8 in
and you make a chisel pan at 12 is that
enough of a root Zone to graze a crop
in here's a photograph from someone
sales literature where they're selling a
ripper and I love this when I was out
there doing his last tillage operation I
think he got stuck here and I don't know
how he got out but you can tell he had
that big white discer field cator and he
came and he drove around here and hung
that big wide disc or field cator over
that wet spot I have to till it to dry
it out out he turned plenty wide so he
wouldn't get stuck and came back and
dried out the rest of it
right every time you do that you now
packed it tighter that next time it'll
stay wet longer because the water can't
soak in I gave this presentation one
time in Ohio and I had a guy come up to
me he says I run a tile business there's
guys who have this problem that hire me
to cut in a random tile line to drain
that wet spot I go yeah he says when I
do that I usually cut the pattern tile
that was already
installed and it's because they created
a compaction layer above the pattern
tile again I've seen it here in South
Dakota people are putting in tile to get
rid of water I'm going like no save the
water use the water that's not I get rid
of it well you saw the tire tracks there
maybe I switched to tracks less
compaction right tracks work because of
a couple things one it is lower PSI on
the soil surface I can do that with
inflated tires as well it's also got
more axles that's sort of axle one axle
two these two together probably carry
the weight of axle three these axle for
again think about trucks when we go to
the field or go to the road to carry
more weight without destroying the road
we add more axles on a truck let's do
that in our Fields as well I love toe
carts I love things that put more axles
out there to carry the load because it's
a lower weight per axle in but again
you're not doing yourself a favor if
you're doing tail
AG farmer friend of mine from Illinois
he's been chiseling for years he's got
compaction layer down there about
chiseling depth Harvest time he's got
riced tires on his combine some people
call them logger tires if you're not
familiar with them they're a real tall
lug to cut down through anybody's ever
put rice lug tires in their combine
admits two things one they admit they
have no soil structure they need that
deep lug to cut through the mush to cut
down to number two they admit they have
a compaction layer and that's where
they're going to get their
traction now anybody brave enough to
raise your hand do have rice leg tires
in your
combine we've done some dumb things at
tell guys because we're destroying our
soil
structure okay Paul pan at 8 in a chisel
pan at 12 50% deeper shank spacing
equals operating depth the V rippers
were born 18 to 20 inches deep 18 to 20
inch shank spacing and you got to like
your fuel man and buy that big
tractor and we come along and we smooth
it all out so we can plant destroyed the
Sol structure now we packed it
down you see what's coming we've done
some dumb things haven't we
is 18 to 20 inches enough of a RIT
Zone that's me in my younger
day this is that Husker Harvest days DMI
was showing off their new deep Ripper
30in shank spacing that run 30 inches
deep remember you got to go 50% deeper
than the 20-inch
layer fortunately we've not seen a lot
those Nebraska you probably haven't seen
too many in South Dakota because we
haven't till the soils when they're that
wet like they do back east again never
tillette soil you're going to create
compaction simple as that it's 30-in
enough RIT
Zone look close under here this is in
farm Journal Magazine on a contest I had
said I built the best Mike Peeper
compaction doesn't have a chance and
Mike Peeper deep rips with this rig he
designed and built 13 foot wide
Implement takes 320 horsepower to
pull earlier I said you got to like your
fuel man Mike's Fuel Man M's
mic we've done some dumb things guys
let's go to noil Dwayne is going to talk
about let mother do it mother nature
freest sty wedding and drying Roots
build soil structure and leave residue
out there it's the residue that's going
to make that system work and again a lot
of guys say well do I need to go out and
rip that up do I need to do strip tail
to me strip tail is a temporary tool to
get rid of a compaction ler that may
have been caused from years of tillage
to open it up to get the crop plant and
then next year I can go no tail rent the
tool you don't need it every year once
you get rid of the pan if you don't
reform it that's how strip till works
you get rid of the pan of the first trip
don't reform it do some digging spend
some time on the spade look what you've
got there now if you're digging and your
roots look something like this there's
no root restricting layer the pan
doesn't necessarily mean you got to do
tillage a root restricting layer does a
water restricting layer does break that
up iron can do it Roots can do it I
prefer Roots because they'll build soil
structure this one's interesting that's
uh that living history of farming deor
years ago there's a display there that's
my finger point The Roots went all the
way to the
floor those roots went down and they
actually spread out below the tillage
layer with no residue up here there's no
solar moisture up there there's no roots
up there now let's think about that
quick quarter inch rain that blows
through on a summer thunderstorm soaks
in about an inch no roots to pick that
up it dries out
I'm a no tailer I got residue up here I
Got Roots up here that same rain means a
lot to me meant nothing to my till
neighbor so again think about the root
system look see what youve got in the
soil leave residue out there this is one
of our Fields already planted residue
everywhere that's what we want to see
that residue is going to be that mulch
to keep the soil cooler and wetter at
planting time yeah yes a little bit but
it's definitely going to keep it cooler
and wetter the rest of the growing
season that's what makes the money you
know this past year there was a lot of
shortages of feed you know I can't fault
someone who has to keep their livestock
alive maybe this is a cheap form of feed
for them but you know what it's a double
whamming when he looks at what happens
to the soil system as we take it away
for the guys who got greedy are selling
their
residue think of every one of those
Bales at least is a $20 bill and about a
th000 pounds of residue there you're
going to put on at least 20 pounds of
extra nutrients to pay for that which
you just hauled away but think about
what happens to the soil itself I'm
hauling away carbon that I can't buy at
the elevator as we look at the a lot of
people say that's already got half cover
you know nrcs will tell you half cover
is good for erosion control well when it
comes to moisture reducing evaporation
Norm Clocky is an irrigation especially
down at K State he's been doing some
work on measuring evaporation from
residue covered soil surfaces with bear
he's measuring about 8/10 of an inch or
800 an inch per day you'll say well
that's not much multiply 100 day growing
season that's 8 in of water loss to
evaporation as he left cover out there
7/10 7/10
710 100% cover was 510 that's
three hund times 100 days is three
inches of water difference I looked at
that and said wait a minute conservation
Tilly says 30% cover Cuts erosion and a
half 50% even 75% cover didn't cut water
loss much why and Norman explained it to
me this way he says you know you build
the best house you can build you got r19
insulation of the walls and R30
insulation of the ceilings and these
triple pane windows and the kids go out
the door and leave the door open and all
the heat gets
out water does the same thing when it
comes to residue cover it follows a
lease path resistance preferential flow
and the water goes out of the soil the
water vapor he says you want at least
80% 100% is better leave the soil
covered you can't afford to sell it
because you just lost three inches of
water in this case also leave it upright
standing catch the snow that is moisture
I don't want that to blow away and I
want to catch it uniformly you know too
often I hear from producers that you
know Hilltop doesn't produce much but
boy those valleys sure do but if they
did something like this and they lost
all this moisture and they tilted and
lost even more moisture but down in The
Valleys where all their water ran off or
all the snow accumulated that's why
there's
differences this is a noer left his
residue standing he's got about the same
snow catch everywhere that's going to be
more uniform soil temperature more
uniform soil moisture for planting next
spring compared to this one so again
leave the residue leave it standing
upright upright anchored attached I
don't have to cut it compared to
flattened since it's attached when I'm
going through it the soil holds it so I
can pass across it I love my residue I
want to leave it there uh here's an
example from our research farm corn our
corn residue we cut pretty high it's
rubbing the paint off of our front axle
of the tractor off of the planter
toolbar these are two visitors from
United Kingdom they couldn't believe in
they had to take pictures I had to take
a picture of them taking pictures but
again you see how tall the residue is a
lot of people say well all that residue
holds a soil cold and wet well if you
knock it down early and you make a mat
you don't get any air movement down the
soil surface I leave it standing as long
as I can so I get air movement of this
whole surface so I get in there to plant
earlier I knock it down at planting time
you notice there's not a whole bunch of
root balls rolled out we're planted down
the old road the soil biological life
and long-term no tail is that the root
ball rots out from underneath it doesn't
roll over when you hit it with a planter
in fact the so biologic activi is once I
get the residue in contact with that so
biological life my res disappears in a
hurry hey that's okay it's breaking down
now releasing carbon dioxide into the
canopy it's releasing carbon into the
soil releasing nutrients into the soil
when my next crop is
growing compared to my neighbor who did
tillage this fall it's releasing all
that stuff now and his next crop won't
be growing for another six months so
again I want the residue to break down
when the next crop is there now I apply
it down the old row for crops and
rotation for corn on corn we actually go
beside the old row beside the old row
for more uniform depth control more
uniform seed placement if you really
want to wear out your tractor tires real
fast plant exactly between the old rows
and you'll wear them out because you're
driving on the old row so again I leave
the residue in place I love rotation I
love wheat wheat gives me a cool
seasoned grass to go along with my warm
seasoned grass of corn my warm season
broad life is soybeans as I go to the
soybeans into wheat in this case
Southeast Nebraska a lot of guys say you
can't plant soybeans till after May 5th
conventional utilties because the soil
is not warm enough yet May 5th I already
had them up and growing because I
planted them in April 15th into 87
bushel wheat
straw the soil structure is such the
excess water soaked away cold wet soil
temperatures is because you can't soak
away the water build the structure soak
it down deeper and no tilling into heavy
wheat straw is not a problem now let's
go back to this I started
earlier half inch doesn't sound like
much been doing a lot of work in my uh
early days I had research grants with
rainfall simulator to measure the
effects of residue and reducing the
erosion and that 30% level in
conservation compliance came from
research like this Across the Nation we
started doing demos for extension type
meetings where we put out 100% cover no
cover on the other side we had 30% maybe
we had 50% we had this different things
every time you ran the research every
time you ran the demo residue reduced
erosion every time we did that looked at
the runoff we says boy residue didn't
change the runoff much you know at the
time the storm's occurring it doesn't
change it much but when you look at what
happens when the residue is gone and
when you build soil structure there are
big differences big differences let's
come back to evapo transpiration the
measurements typically about 1/4 of our
water that comes from rainfall is
evaporated off from the soil surface off
a wet crop canopy off a wet residue lost
to evaporation quicker you close the
canopy the less this will be
now the rest of the water goes through
the soil system into the roots and
transpired by the crop to keep the crop
cool and to grow more
crop now some people say take all the e
out of ET well you can cut it in half
roughly because it's still going to come
off wet surface wet residue but the more
I can get into the soil the more goes
through the crop the more yield I get I
throw this up these are Nebraska numbers
just to give you a quick reference in
your mind western Nebraska ET is lower
than Eastern Nebraska wait a minute
isn't hotter and drier out west
the reason it's less out there is they
use shorter seasoned crops if you get a
90day corn versus 120-day Corn that's
the difference in water use it's growing
longer uses more water and look this
direction alphaalpha grows only about
eight months a year compared to corn and
beans only about five months a year
wheat grows in the cool of the winter
cool of the spring uses less water so
there's all sorts of things affect ET
but think about those when you're using
water a cover crop in the offseason of
corn soybeans is in this cooler season
it's going to use less water simply
because it is a less water intensive
time a year something grows year round
uses more water again if you got excess
water grow something to use the water so
that's why I just throw these up for et
when nor Clocky was at Nebraska he was
measuring ET and he separated out again
what was off the evaporation what was
transpiration and what was amazing sort
of is 16.8 was
transpiration I can show you producers
in Nebraska that pump 20 to 30 in of
water a year which means they're wasting
irrigation water that means they aren't
even using the
rainfall again vaporation let's cut that
in half if we can Norman went out there
and he took just 5,000 pounds per acre
equivalent of wheat straw spread it out
there two different years data here just
by taking a bare soil and covering it he
cut evaporation roughly in half growing
a crop he also cut it in half because he
cut the wind and sun off the soil
surface and residue in a crop cut it
even more
yet grow something protect the soil keep
the Sun and wind off the soil surface a
lot of people say well I never have this
condition over here sure you do if you
don't have a cover crop you've done
tillage you've got that if you leave the
residue there it's worth a lot more if I
do residue and a cover crop it's worth a
lot more to save water he's norm since
moved to Garden City Kansas here's corn
residue wheat residue straight no
tilling in soybeans and corn this is
simply this difference now so he did the
math for you
he finds two to four to almost five
inches of water saved by reducing that
evaporation so let's put this on here
I'm going start running total here by
the
way you know here's a crop sunflowers
sunflowers supposed to be drought
resistant because they Root Down Deeper
right 2005 was a drought here in
Southeast Nebraska the sunflowers burned
up because of a lack of
residue if you don't have residue there
and evaporation I just lost five inches
that was my crop
2005 there were some neighbors there
that says you know I have to chop silage
to harvest what I can to feed my Liv
stock true now the next spring when they
went in and planted their corn it was a
dry year that corn burned up there's not
an ear there on part of the field they
left to run the combine through just so
he get his insurance payment had to run
a grain yield had residue there the corn
is still green and it's forming an
ear the residue are you took away that
year cost him the next year the little
bit he left was a plus now the guys are
starting to argue well you get the
drought year and you got that short corn
out there what do you do there's a lot
of guys run their combine through it
just to spread the residue and process
the residue they're not taking it away
because they know the value of the
residue so a researcher out that way
West Central research extension centers
at North Plat Nebraska he went in
straight soybean residue and raked away
some and left the other there now I did
a nutrient testing he made sure
nutrients wen't limiting factor this
simply the residue mulch he irrigated
the rest of the field based upon the
residue
level this was under irrigated because
of the viation and you can see how much
yield he lost well some guys say we just
irrigate more to make up for this wait
that costs money don't do that or you're
the dry Lander here was wheat after
harvest left the straw in place and in
part of the field he bailed the straw
because he needed some straw baales gave
up 20
bushels this guy figured out he buys his
baales from the neighbor because the
neighbor hasn't figured it out yet he
leaves his residue in the
field the next year Steve Melvin at our
Curtis research Farm has a good rainfall
year his Dy yields weren't that much
reduced yeah there some look they were
reduced both though when he removed
residue we got guys down there in
Southeast Nebraska that don't even allow
Sil to be chopped in their Farms because
the yield they give up when that residue
disappears and one of those Farms is our
University Nebraska research Farm the
Agronomy group already figured this out
and the animal science group is mad
because they got to buy the silage from
The Neighbors The Neighbors haven't
figured it out yet again that residue is
what drives this soil system I can't
afford to give it up here's back to my
tillage plots in uh 2005 first week of
June we had five days in a row over 100
degree heat now it cooled off and it
rained where there's no residue in the
till that sor basically went dormant now
it didn't die you can see all the plants
are still there but look where how
healthy that growth is when the rain
came this took off and we didn't expect
too much yield difference when the
combine rolled it was 35 bushel
difference 2000 was a year that during
the growing season we got 11 inches of
rain County average of soybeans that
year was 23 Bush per acre or 25 bushel
per acre I'm sorry my tilled soybeans
were 23 on 11 in of rain my notail was
47 I can't give up that
residue earlier I said rainfall
simulator we said not much difference in
runoff big difference in erosion we had
one site we're doing all this research
that uh when we stood there and on the
tilled side we got run off after about
20 minutes of water applied that's an
inch of water in 20
minutes and all the farmers standing
there said see tilling it you open it up
the water can soak again on the other
side the residue was standing we stood
there for an hour and a half three and
3/4 inches of water applied before we
saw any runoff and we said boy this
site's not like the other 21 sites that
we just done this one's wrong I'm sorry
to say this was the right
site Charlie fster had a no tail as a
Cham fellow versus tillage fellow what
this plot was he' been there for 13
years
already 13 years a no tail build it such
that three and 3/4 inches of water
soaked in before we saw the first runoff
compared to this one one inch of water
that single storm is two and 3/4 inch of
water difference because the so
structure of longterm
NOA again long-term no till this is from
my tillage plots tile Spade full of soil
you see the good Peds and Aggregates you
can see where water can soak in compared
to the tilled where it's denser you
can't see the water soak in now before
taking this picture I should have lined
this up 4 inches lower than that because
the soil surface is 4 inches lower
wasn't thinking when I snapped the
picture but now some interesting work
coming out of France see that good soil
structure the heat from the earth Rises
up through those same holes and they are
measuring in no tail fields in March
being about 5 to 10 degrees warmer than
tilled fields in March it's because this
tillage making it more dense and no poor
space there the Heat Can't
rise I started paying attention to that
on our usage Farm we started measuring
so temperatures our no tail where the
water can soak in and heat can come up
as the same soil temperatures are tilled
in fact with the soil structure we can
plant no tail before our till neighbors
can plant theirs and again remember I
said I had soybeans into heavy wheat
straw 15th of April and Convention till
neighbors aren't plant soybeans till May
5th because it's too cold no tail soil
structure solves a lot of the problems
when you get air exchange gas exchange
water
movement we've done some measurements on
infiltration I use controll wheel
traffic as well Jim mentioned that in
his final present or slide there till
2/10 inch per hour could soak in 410 on
the soft row we haven't driven and this
has hadn't been driven on it for more
than 25
years but the tillage makes that top
layer so it doesn't take in water very
fast we pulled out the nrcs soil survey
and it said that the intake rate should
be between 210 and 610 because of the
clay content of Sly clay LOM soil that
was now what was interesting though this
is saturated for more than 24 hours
before he took this measurement so this
is not just initial intake this is
actually what's moving through the soil
go to the notail there's 610 that's the
high side of the two to four 2 to six
it's over 4 in per hour there any of you
who visits Dakota lakes Dwayne will show
you this on his long-term noil with that
water can just disappear it soaks in
when you build that
structure Southeast Nebraska it's the
typical spring thunderstorm blew through
and actually late spring 6inch rain came
overnight from June 12th to 13th we're
out there walking around taking pictures
and as we're taking pictures of this
it's got a crust on Terrace is over top
Terrace is washed out the farmer drove
up he just shaking his head said
worthless rain just like anybody else I
said how much did you get he says six
Ines worthless rain crusted the soil
Washed Out The Terraces when am I going
to get in there when's it's it going to
be dry enough for me to replant the
grain sorghum worthless
rain his neighbor acrossed the fence
long-term no
tiller sorum's already up soil
structures there took a soil moisture
Pro Rod had a full soil moisture profile
to 6 feet deep and sorghum June 13th 6
foot of moisture he says beautiful
rain the difference of so structure
guys all right I put a question mark on
the six you don't always get that kind
of thunderstorm it's impressive yes
we've easily measured two extra inches
of water because of better infiltration
less
runoff and again going back to that
11inch rainfall year 61 with tillage to
the line no till 121
that's what we see when you get that
infiltration and residue and soil
structure and remember I'm adding this
is working together areal view of that
research Farm 10 miles east of Lincoln
it's a terorist farm terorists are put
in back in the 50s and 60s when he said
we got to control runoff you know what
with controlled wheel traffic and
long-term no tail and nice broad crop
rotation we have next to no runoff very
seldom do these Terra see
water right here is a repair and buffer
Strip This Terrace basically defines
only runoff that comes through that
buffer strip is off of this field that
buffer strip was put in in 1998 because
everyone says we're going to put in
buffers to filter everything coming out
of the
runoff was it R I think you said it
buffers were a
Band-Aid this field was no tilled about
10 years already by then 98 they put in
the buffer 99 they put in eight runoff
sampers in front of the buffer and four
behind so they can compare the water in
water out see how affected the buffer
was about five years ago they quit
putting the runoff Samplers out there in
the spring because they never measured
runoff into that
buffer it all stays in that field
doesn't run
off we raise 250 bushel of corn dry land
down here dropping populations in
Dryland 33,000 when our neighbors are
raising 142 is the county average and
they're dropping about
25,000 I'm treating it like irrigated
because we're using our
water now again our neighbors they're
using their terrorist
we're keeping our
water all right you've seen the running
total 5 to 12 I easily get the five
extra did a meeting down Boot Hill in
Missouri I was there for three days and
rained five inches they get 50 inches of
rain there they had land levelers trying
to get the land level to get rid of the
water then you looked in the background
and they had pivots I'm going 50 inches
of water and you got pivots yeah when
the rain stops in June it stops s till
September we need irrigation I go 50 in
of rain they have a tilled soil that's
not letting the water soak in it's all
running off they need irrigation he's
been there he's
nodding we go to Minnesota we switch to
Noel we go to Iowa Illinois wherever we
switched to noil we used to be corn
soybeans with tillage we had runoff we
had evaporation and we had 30 inches
rain 40 inch of rain whatever they get
and they save 5 to
12 remember Cornell used
16.8 they say 5 to 12 what's the first
thing they do they complain about cold
wet soil they say I'm going to get rid
of that by doing strip tail blow off
that spring soil moisture they also set
themselves up again this is a norm
Clocky leaving the door open that soil
moisture leaves them all season long not
just that time of year all year long so
again some people till the water out and
they continue to lose the water all year
for me it's up to you what you do with
the extra water that no tail saves you
know a drought year that's your crop
in a non drought year that's opportunity
to do something else you know irrigators
in Nebraska the average for Center per
irrigation is about $15 an acre inch
saing five inches the low end is 75
bucks an acre more profit you're the dry
Lander the low end again remember I said
5 to 12 corn responds about 12 bushels
per acre inch 5 time 12 is 60 extra
bushels of
corn we are running at R moral Farm past
5 years we are more than 60 bushels of
County average on a Noto corn we're
running over 200 Bush of corn where the
county average is 140 that's where my
extra water is beans 3 and2 Time 5 is
172 again that's extra profit if you use
your
water comes down to can you use your
water can you store your water out west
used to be wheat F because they didn't
think they had enough water grow crop
every year they're using noil using
residue and they're raising the crop
every year they're using their extra
water noil gives them
down South Oklahoma and Kansas used to
be a lot of wheat fow they went to no
till they learned they can raise
continuous crops they went to no till
and they actually learned they can use
double crop because they're growing
wheat that uses less water in the
offseason they go beans uses the water
when the water is available comes down
to timing now when your water
available producer I know in
Pennsylvania he says you know we got wet
Springs I grow alala because it's a high
water Ed crop it starts using water
clear back in March I take first cutting
and by then it's already used 8 to 10
inch of water he says I wait for
regrowth I plant corn I spray out the
alal and I raise good corn he gets 40
inch of rain 10 15 went to the AL Alpha
the rest went to the corn he says I got
conventional till neighbors who plow up
their Al Alpha to kill it set themselves
for erosion and runoff they plant their
corn and the erosion and runoff no water
getting into the solar profile and their
corn droughts out says I'm a no tell I
got two crops and they got zero they're
using the extra
water extreme case in Nebraska
after Corn Harvest plant wheat planted
in skip RS you plant your soybeans that
when you combine your wheat your
soybeans are already there they're using
extra water now I say extreme case in
Nebraska this is the Dryland corner on a
pivot the beans got up this high and
died because the wheat already used all
the
water now back east in Illinois Indiana
on in Ontario they love it they call it
relay cropping we got a Living Root
there almost a year round with
irrigation we got that Living Root and
they're raising good wheat and good corn
or good soybeans using that extra water
and they're keeping track of the
irrigation they it's only putting on six
extra inches of water because the no
tail and the rainfall they only need 60
extra for two crops in a year so again
think about using the water and again I
look at how much water can you store we
have some potential losses if we have a
c profile it's already full we get extra
water in Nebraska we have trouble with
deep percolation taking nitrogen down to
our drinking water if we use some of
that water growing a cover crop we
reduce the nitrate leeching Dwayne is
going to talk more about Catch and
Release nutrients we have a crusted soil
or saturated soil again we lose water
build structure protect it or if it's
unprotected soil we got evaporation we
lose water leave residue out there and
again once you're full it's wasted now a
normal spring in Nebraska we hope to
have our solar moisture profile refilled
by
March we don't plant till maybe April or
May I got an opport for cover crop to
use water if it's going to be a dry year
maybe I'll look at a fall cover crop to
empty out water in the fall such that I
can save water in the spring you go huh
think about it if it's got a wet fall
and it fills up right away everything in
the winner is
wasted sometimes you make the cover crop
decision on the Fly And the main thing
is I want to grow the water rather than
lose it because I'm going to be growing
root and growing soil structure talk
quickly about cover crops here for my
last get 17 minutes that's not bad then
Ralph derps friend of mine he's a crop
consultant uh learned no tail back at
least 40 years ago and he's been sort of
the leader in getting no started in
South America he's living in Paraguay
now but he started with German
government he's gone into areas that
have never been tilled never been farmed
before and they're planting no till and
I say that because they're not used to
the big tractors we have they're using a
lot smaller tractors they have not
invest in the horsepower for tillage
they've never seen the soil bear they
think it's logical to have it
covered we've seen it be thanks to
Grandpa thanks to Dad so we're not used
to seeing the residue near as much but
they're out there planting and what
they're doing is they're using cover
crops to provide extra carbon biomass to
the soil system to use some water to
protect the soil to build the soil and
to them cover crops is a
no-brainer now the interesting thing I
when you start thinking about it and we
saw this on slide earlier but we think
about when is the crop using water
when's the water available
our summer planted crops and you could
substitute just move this axis over and
call this fall or winter crops if you're
doing wheat but think about it they take
off growing in the spring corn that's
sometime in May they're really actively
growing they reach a peak in July they
taper off that in September they're done
using water that's when we produce the
biomass that's when it uses the water
but from an ARS study where they took
this they said we missed some
opportunities to produce I love their
big words resource simulation dry matter
production I say they basically they're
losing the opportunity to use some water
and some carbon dioxide and also
sunlight now think about it sunlight we
don't store at least not in the crop
field carbon dioxide we don't use in a
crop field in the off seon now when a
crop is growing there is so that's what
the cover crop is for now water we can
store and some people argue well this
water it's not really lost if I can
store it and use it for next crop but
too often I see where the soils might be
already full and this is now deep
leeching or it's deep percolation or
it's evaporation off an unprotected
surface in the spring with heavy spring
rains it is again again by planting a
cover crop I can use some water and
accumulate some biomass and more
importantly get some roots in that soil
and use some of that carbon dioxide and
sunlight rather than waste to it use
some water but I have to manage the
water and that's why I show the break
off
here if it is a wet spring you let that
covered crop grow longer use some water
because you got plenty of water and that
breakoff might even occur out here or if
it's a dry spring it might break off
here or if it's always dry in your area
PL a cover crop that winter kills and
there's nothing even appears here again
the water management is up to you a
little bit on your risk and a little bit
on what you're trying to accomplish and
when I say what are you trying to
accomplish again here's down in South
America when they first started raising
soybeans down there a lot of people said
well it's beans on beans every acre
every year and that's what kills our
soybeans Market in the US I had an
opportunity to go down to Brazil and Ray
W was along that trip last year and we
saw a lot of Acres beans on beans every
year but you know what after soybean
Harvest they had enough growing season
enough sunlight and carbon dioxide and
water they grew a cover crop this is
black oats in this case rolled down or
it could have been a short season forage
because they had livestock or it could
have been corn or cotton and they grew
those through the winter months again
using a crop groin when the water's
available is what they're doing now when
it comes to The Pest Management beans on
beans when that first rainstorm comes
and hits that black oats residue how
much Bean disease is going to Splash on
that new beans
crop none a cover crop can be a pest
management tool reducing Splash in this
case the thing I encircled here is this
tree in the background that's the same
tree a few weeks later and you look at
that and say the beans don't look bad
and you look at that and you go where
did the rest of that residue go the
biological life is digesting it putting
in the system and I said that's when I
want it to happen when the next crop is
growing I thought it was pretty neat I
thought it was real neat when Ralph
showed me
this that's what it does when you grow a
crop cover crop and using the sunlight
and carbon dioxide when it's available
using the water to grow the soil by
having that Living Root in there it's
feeding the soil system so what do you
grow I've got this seed box in my pickup
right now these some different cover
crops I've planted in different plots
people always ask me what do you plant I
go what are you trying to do the laundry
list that I borrowed from under Nebraska
nrcs and their cover crop plan they put
erosion control on top that's what the
name actually come from is cover to
reduce the soil
erosion if I want erosion control I want
to quit growing something like a grass
to get it up there and absorb rain do
impact what if I'm doing nutrient
capture nutrient cycling I want
something takes up a lot of nutrients
and then releases it slowly next year
and again Dwayne's going talk catch to
release nutrients improve solo Health
any Living Root will do that water
management the two-edged
sword you use the water if you have it
or better yet grow some residue to keep
the Sun and wind off the Sol surface to
conserve the water that you don't have
it can work both ways increase
biodiversity by simply getting a cool
season versus a warm season a r versus a
grass just change the biodiversity to
change that so biological life balance
carbonation ratio if you want residue to
hang around a long time you want a high
carbon out there corn stocks wheat straw
will hang around a long time compared to
peas or soybeans will break down in a
hurry because it's
a low carbon higher nitrogen ratio well
again if I want to Decay my residue and
I got a lot of cornstalks or wheat
stubble there put a legum out there you
Decay your residue in a hurry or if I'm
like me I got a lot of Sol biological
life and I don't want to Decay as fast
I'm going to put more high carbon stuff
out there more Grass more Rye to get the
residue to hang around longer nitrogen
fixation that's with the early days most
people looked at cover crops to grow
nitrogen because we were organic
producers before they invented
fertilizer well we got organic producers
or we got others who are cutting their
nitr because they're growing on their
own reduce compaction it's a two-edged
sword there as well the one is yes it
can when you got a good vigorous roote
growing but the more important thing is
the good vigorous route actually
provides some soil structure and
stability to reduce the compaction from
next trips on the field getting that
road out there weed suppression the
right selected cover crop can suppress
the next weeds you just want to make
sure you select the right cover crop
doesn't suppress your next crop and
again that's why I can't tell you what
you need to plant because I don't know
what you're doing next Forge of grazing
I do that for the soil system but again
some years drought conditions maybe I
need that for my four-legged livestock e
T-Bones out of and so again we got to
think about it like I said a lot of
cover crop tours out there you go out
there and look at them lot usually
they're planted in single species just
so you can see the individual crop you
get benefits of mixing them in a
cocktail the benefits build and it's uh
really helps you out that way but this
is a set of legumes then see how much
nitrogen they fix planted into wheat
stubble or this case into wheat stubble
cover he used a sorum sedan grows in the
heat in summer doesn't use a lot of
water but the good news is it's up and
growing that when his pastures and
rangeland need a rest he can put the
livestock over here and they got feed
recovery time on pasture and rangeland
is worth big bucks that'll pay for your
cover crop because you get the cattle
off of there so again we got to think
about how we manage the
system again with selecting a cover crop
first question what do you want Want To
Do With It Go on a planet because it's
the hottest topic out there that's not
the reason to do it that's why so many
lemings go over the cliff they've never
asked why it's just everyone else is
doing it no why do you want to do it
again what do you select then can you
grow it it doesn't matter if it's
something that really works great in
South America and they can't grow here
black oats for instance if you want to
raise black oats for seed you got to
move South a long ways it only takes
about 170 days to mature it now for a
cover crop I don't need 170 days because
it doesn't need to mature can you manage
it can you kill it can you plant it can
you row again you would select something
you can't will it affect the next crop
one of my favorite examples is at
Harvest time when you're hauling wheat
to the elevator and they refuse it
because of
scab and someone walks up to you and say
I'll buy that wheat from you because I'm
going to use it as a cover crop seed
you'd be glad just to sell it right well
I plant that scab wheat as a cover crop
and it comes up and I spray it up before
it makes a head and every gets heads
scab who cares I'm planting my next crop
is soybeans who cares I plant my next
crop is corn you serum heads scab and
ferium stock crot is the same ferium
guys you just shot yourself in a foot
when it come to raising corn if you use
wheat as a cover crop in front and had
ferium so again will it affect the next
crop I see the same thing with
sunflowers and white mold things like
that so be careful what would the seed
cost my cheapest cover crop seed has
been floor sweepings
well my next cheapest has been bin run
grein serum you know Milo is not worth
much Milo is planted at 5 pounds the
acre Bush Milo 56 pounds it'll P 10
acres for about three bucks four bucks
five bucks depending upon the price Milo
is a warm seasoned grass following wheat
it's perfect because that's the cool
season grass so again how does it fit
what will the seed cost the best is what
is left in your seed shed when you're
done seeding dump it all together and
plant it because you know you can grow
it all well help the so system I sure
hope so that's why I'm doing it and
again some cover crops won't help as
much again different species out there
there's
flax flax I used to not think too much
of it until we had 2in hail for 20
minutes with two inches of rain with 80
mph
winds everything in the area was
destroyed except for my flax cover crop
this isn't it this is a different plot
the FL cover crop is such a small
spining thing it sprang back up and the
day after the hill storm you're walking
out there go how come it Miss that strip
it didn't that plant was that
resilient now I contrast that to this
one right next to it that's sunm it's a
legum fixes nitrogen Sun hemp as a name
implies is a
rope I would spray that out sooner than
this producer did because you know as a
rope any residue mover on your planter
it's turning wraps up so tight that you
need a torch to get it out
this producer says don't run residue
movers you just plant right through it I
go that works he goes great it works so
again what are you after if you're after
residue cover grasses will provide that
fastest if you're after nitrogen it has
to be a legum and you have to inoculate
it with a proper inoculant for that
species just because you've planted
soybeans before doesn't mean their isob
are there it's going to help you on peas
or vet or even alphalpha they're all
different you use the right one brascas
a lot of people look at them getting rid
of the compaction because the Braska
family includes the oil seed radish and
the turnips those big Roots but they're
also notorious for residue cycling
because they will break down the residue
underneath
them others the others category that's I
already showed you flax that's not any
of these sunflowers is other
biodiversity is what I'm after cool
season versus warm season it's pretty
obvious to really get the good growth
you plant the opposite what your cash
crop is following wheat Harvest a cool
season crop I do a warm SE seon because
In The Heat Of July and August you want
a warm season sorum Sudan or soybeans or
cow peas that grow out there now going
the other way after a warm season crop
like Corner soybeans I'm going to go
cool season my aern winter peas even a
spring pea oats all my cool season crops
grass versus broadleaf versus cocktail
again that's balancing the carbon
nitrogen ratio cocktail gets you the
balance of everything and it gives you
some risk management as well what if it
is too hot and dry and the cool season
legum you planted burned up while my
warm season grass might be still growing
so again it gives you some management if
you need to learn more about cover crops
ARS out of Mandan put together this
periodic table just like the one you
hated in chemistry it is sorted by down
the column the related again grasses
down the ends simpler things on top more
complex than the bottom then it's
grouped also within column by legumes
here Broad Leaf here warm season cool
season and they got these little
footnote things in the corners here on
their life cycle their water use and how
they grow again you'll say huh well if
I'm in an area of wind erosion I want an
upright if I'm in an area of water
erosion I want something that lays flat
again just think about differences what
you need out there but then you're
saying okay what the world's a looping
you click on that and if you run it
online it goes straight to the file or
you can download it to your computer
it's a PDF file it's available again on
that website you click on loopin and it
comes up saying here's what it looks
like here's what it is cool season Broad
Leaf legume goes down low water use acid
soil if you're going to feed it it's got
some protein if you want the bonus
points in your CSP plan it attracts the
pollinators you know what it doesn't
form my micis
associations again will it build soil
this one not as fast because it's not
going to help the fungi near as much or
you click on serial Ry one of my
favorites because I don't raise a lot of
wheat in our area uh cool season grass
following Corner soybeans it's great
anel upright upright catches more snow
for me high water use well that's why I
be careful when I kill it in the spring
do I kill it late or early is it a wet
or dry spring go on down here you know
uh will form micro Riz Association very
good at Scavenging
nitrogen again once you decide why you
need a cover crop you can go to a table
like this and help you decide which
cover crop do you need again the
cocktails are nice here's after wheat
Harvest a cocktail it had a cool season
legum warm season legon brasas warm
season grass cool season grass this is
after the first Frost the warm season
grass of the Sorghum sedan frosted off
the cool season grasses underneath are
still growing in fact they'll really
take off now that the weather cool down
likewise the brasas are still growing
down here they'll take cooler
temperatures again when you start
thinking about managing the cover crop
can you kill it can you manage it a
cover crop roller rollers work great on
a single species because you know
exactly when to roll it you're supposed
to roll it about the time it's star to
do reproduction
now you got this cocktail mix here when
do you roll
that I'm not exactly sure well wait a
minute if this already Frost killed and
the rest of this is going to frost kill
maybe I don't even need to worry about a
roller so again how you're going to
terminate depends what you're growing
the cover crop rollers they love them in
South
America here's again from Ralph derps
this is a black oats crop rolled down no
herbicide those that black oats is
expressing all the weeds raising that
corn so again weed control there some
guys say I can use till to terminate the
cover crop remember they told us for
years you plow under that green manure
crop when it comes to soil biological
life is exactly the worst thing to do
yes I put that residue into the soil but
I destroyed a lot of other stuff as well
we got a grad student in Nebraska
working my PhD in organic weed control
using cover crops he had two four six
and eight species cover crops he found
that once you got to six or eight
species you could suppress weeds
when you're down at two or four you
actually almost increased weeds he found
that when you terminate with a disc you
increased weeds because you planted
every weed seed and you got R rid of the
benefit when he used a blade undercutter
and he left the residue on top then the
8pc cover crop paid for the ganing
production so again we got to think
about what's going on out there don't
use tillage to kill it guys use the
herbicide use the roller or you PL into
it wait before I can tell you to do that
check with your RMA check with your
insurance check with your FSA in
Nebraska I can guarantee you if you do
this your crop is not
insurable if you plant into a cover crop
or worse yet if your cover crop even
heads or buds your next crop is not
insurable we have to kill our cover crop
early in Nebraska if you want crop
insurance but you know what Terry Taylor
in Illinois he's got excess water he's
growing the excess water out he's
planting he's got beautiful mols there
that planter actually was this cover
crop roller who really knocked it back
for him and his one poster herbicide
took care of the rest of it
he didn't have pre didn't have a whole
bunch of other stuff out there but again
we start thinking about it think about
growing it terminating it but why are
you growing it it's going to increase
that soil biological life if you have a
soil surface that has no residue and you
got a lot of
evaporation use a little bit of water to
grow the cover it reduces evaporation I
got to throw up some data and you
mentioned the group up at uh Marlin RoR
up in uh North Dakota bismar you had
about 15 inches of annual rain after p
Harvest he had very little residue he
planted a cover
crop it all Frost killed the next spring
he had beautiful residue and over here
he had no residue and over here he had
weeds where he had the residue he had
less weeds so he saved a herbicide
application he had the residue there it
saved water and when they took these
measurements the day of corn planting in
May going down to 4
foot basically no difference what's
interesting is look on top where there
was no
cover the soil was exposed and it dried
out where he had cover he actually saved
water near the soil surface to plant
into so numbers I got from
Dwayne he only went to 3 feet and this
is 20-inch rainfall area onto a wheat
stubble again with a cover crop that
Frost killed this is spring planting
time he had more moisture near the
surface because he kept the Sun and wind
off the so surface and not only then all
the way until the crop canopy took over
so it saves even more water going into
the next season the cover crop
does again here's on our Rogers Memorial
Farm has two Bush of corn the day after
harvest I'm planting a cover crop Austin
winter peeas a lot of people say you got
too much residue there you know what
that drill just put the residue in
contact with the soo microbes this is
long-term no tail next spring March one
this is the same field we're also
where's all my residue so microbes are
digesting at the cover crop is starting
to grow that's Austin winter peeas March
15th by the time it came time to plant
about April 20th those a peas fixed
about 90 pounds of nitrogen I paid for
the cover crop it cycled my
residue I'm getting excited about cover
crops here's Keith glue extension
educator plant some 20-inch corn in this
demonstration plot this is irrigated
corn on corn with a Sero R cover crop we
had corn Ry cover crop corn R cover crop
R corn cover crop this is the fourth
year corn we took a conventional tilled
field and with seven crops remember four
corn three cover crops we stepped up
biological activity such that here's the
rise sprayed out we're planting the corn
here's a few weeks
later where's all the Rye residue
where's all the irrigated corn residue
breaking down because of the biological
activity fly it on could be an option in
soybeans we're getting good luck in
Nebraska because the soybeans we do it
right before Leaf Drop the seed falls
down in the ground the leaves cover it
up it's the mulch the soybean mulch
allows the cover crop to grow in
corn you fly it on there's a lot up here
in the leaves never make it to the soil
until the combine runs
and you don't make the mulch like the
dropping leaves do we don't recommend it
in Nebraska and corn in fact Lor Alor
nrd will pay the cost of the flying to
put it on because they want the erosion
control helicopter they're using that
the fun thing about a helicopter doesn't
have to return to the airport they put
the totes out the day
before each tote held enough seed for 40
acres helicopter just dropped the tote
slid to the side dump the tote in they
did 1300 acres in one afternoon
and it looks like this then at Harvest
Time this is a sandy soil couldn't store
all the offseason prip his cover crops
already growing when he combine the
beans protection is there keeping the
Sun and wind off the soil surface this
producer reported those Bean the cover
crop corn did about 20 bushel per acre
better than where he had Sandy soils
without a cover crop because he kept the
Sun and wind off the soil
surface other guys spread it with dry
fertilizer guys in Iowa do a lot of that
mix their 1152 with some cover crop seed
when they go out there and spin it they
get enough rain they get the fertilizer
on they get the cover crop up some guys
use the drill they're putting on the
fertilizer for the next crop they're
putting on a cover crop for this crop
again different ways of getting it out
there some put it with the manure now
dry feed lot manure is a little hard but
a lot of Michigan work and Pennsylvania
work mixing in with slurry when they
spread the slurry it gets incorporated
or they spread it with a dry spreader
and then they do a manure application
across the top like with an airway or
something they incorporate it or in this
case feed lot manure spread hair bar to
smooth it out the drill then cut up the
rest of the residue and this is actually
great to reduce nutrient runoff loss
from surface Supply manure because a lot
of those nutrients are now tied up in a
biological form be released
later in corn I say we don't fly it on
if you got hybrid SE corn production
there's not much canopy there they do
fly on at hybrid SE corn production or
they do it when they destroy the mail
row here's the cover crop already
starting to come up here's a few weeks
later when the corn was
harvested I like that hybrid sea corn
production you over fertilize and
overwater the cover crops an excellent
scavenger we already saw a couple of
these I'm going repeat them here's a
seed corn producer that's got a det
tassler he says I detassel my hybrid
Seed corn but you know what the tassel
is not needed in regular corn AFF
pollinated he goes out there and need
hous regular corn and he's blowing cover
crop seed
underneath we already saw this one a lot
of guys say we can't cover much ground
you know what
at it's a nice cover build a bigger
spreader this is 90 ft
wide you can cover some
ground this one's got some ground
clearance and again they're doing that
to get the cover crop seated in that
growing corn but again talk to your
insurance man in Illinois they can do
that in Nebraska if I see that cover
crop and growing corn they're going to
say there new crops growing and your
previous crop is no longer insured
depends talk to them before you do it
again summary after low residue crop
let's grow some
residue after corn Sage or wheat because
there I've got a longer growing season
to do that and again here's the one that
catches a lot of people by surprise if
you got a Sandy so can't can't store all
your offseason preset maybe a cover crop
something to consider use the water when
it's available rather than lose
it biging the soil that black is the
roots get more Roots out there pero
crops cover crops drilled crops winter
crops you're going to build that
soil Carlos coretto about a 40-year no
down South America grain belongs to a
farmer residue belongs to the
soil I believe in that again quick
commercial for our crop production crop
scoty newsletter Nebraska with that I
bumped the pause button here so it
didn't vibrate on me it says I got five
minutes left but I'm sorry I went into
your
break I'll be around to answer questions
during the break because I don't want to
show you visiting our exhibitors because
they help pay for this
[Applause]